last saturday vladimir putin held
nuclear drills for all the world to see
this sunday he put them on high alert
dear colleagues
you can see that western countries are
not only taking unfriendly economic
actions against our country i mean the
illegal sanctions that everyone knows
about but also the top officials of
leading nato countries are allowing
themselves to make aggressive statements
with regards to our country
that's why i'm ordering the defence
minister and the chief of general staff
to put deterrence forces on high combat
alert
even his defense minister looks
concerned
he's put his nuclear forces on high
alert
what does that mean and how worried
should we be alerting could mean an
increase in general force readiness it
could mean
forces from russia's 12 gumo which are
in charge of russia's nuclear arsenal
pulling nuclear warheads out of central
storage
bring him to places where means of
delivery are stored things like
strategic bombers part of russia's
long-range aviation it could mean
a higher alert level of russia strategic
bomber force it could mean more
strategic
uh ballistic missile submarines being
put out to sea right or it could be a
larger number of strategic bomber
patrols or things of sort of over
signaling of that nature
russian troops have pushed into
ukraine's second largest city kharkiv
but their advance does not appear to be
the slam dunk straight to kiev invasion
that they'd hoped for
but they have deployed just a fraction
of the military power they have on
standby so that could all change
sky news has confirmed the presence of
thermobaric rockets in southern ukraine
an especially nasty weapon that the
russians are known to have which sucks
in oxygen to create a massive blast
[Applause]
videos like this of a ukrainian soldier
swearing he'll never speak russian again
once this war is done
testament to the fact that ukraine's
military will not go down without a
flight
ukraine agreed today to send a
delegation for talks with the russians
at a site near chernobyl on the border
between ukraine and belarus but they
remained defiant if the order of
president putin
to put on high alert his nuclear weapons
is a direct threat
to use
these nuclear weapons against ukraine
then
i have a very simple message
it will be
a catastrophe for the world
but it will not break us down
[Music]
in russia protesters again took to the
streets across the country those who see
through the propaganda and know this war
is wrong and who aren't deterred by the
inevitable arrests
[Music]
nuclear forces on high alert ukraine
cities under attack and this kind of a
crackdown back home it is a hard sell
even to his own people that this is all
in the name of russia's defense
they don't know why their president is
doing this and the west doesn't either
which makes planning a response to what
is now a nuclear threat that much harder
dana magnay sky news moscow